[music]
the Minister of Defense specially arrived in
Rostov in order to carry out an operation
to destroy a person Wagner, he
used gunners and
helicopter pilots in the dark to destroy us [
music]
the first leadership of the Ministry of Defense, they
carefully deceive the president and the
president receives those reports that
do not correspond in any way to
sti are formed  two agendas, one on
the ground, the other
insisted on the president, and therefore we
listen all day long about 60 destroyed
leopards about 3000 will destroy
enemy soldiers The Ministry of Defense is trying to deceive the
public is trying to
deceive the president and tell the story
that there was
insane aggression from Ukraine and they got
together very badly NATO  to attack Nastya,
therefore, the
special operation is so called on February 24, it
was launched for completely different
reasons
[music]
your intentions were not now
noble Maybe as you were
explained this was a stab in the back of the country and
only the president has the right to
appoint a higher leader of the
armed forces Are you trying
it's a coup d'état
[music]